great it will be for the athletics if
they could get frankie montos to pitch
as well as he did against the astros in
his last start
in this second half of the season
because he's the ball he's strong
he could pitch deep in the ball game and
i think that's something he takes a lot
of pride in
if he can do that as he makes his 19th
start those eight wins
will jump up double figures very quickly
and he lines it into center field
in the alley it's a base hit he'll turn
and burn for two
here's the throw to second base it's
offline and rosario in
with a double that's his 11th on the
year so
two on one out indians with an early
opportunity here
swung on a miss splitter in the dirt
reyes k is not number two that's a big
out
montage throws and it's swung on a high
fly ball playable left center loriana
drifting back he's under it now
he's right there and makes the guess
good job by montas
to work out of the jam the indians fail
to score with the a's coming up in the
bottom half
cal point i want to say paul he's dead
fits very nicely very well with the
toronto blue jays but
you see the young man making his ninth
start first ever against the athletics
he's been primarily out of the bullpen
and
not surprising that his pitch selection
would include mostly
sinker and slider good basketball
painted the outside corner and got him
looking two down
that was a perfect pitch in the pitch
and that's swung on
and driven up the alley right center
nobody's there and that's gonna
crashed off the wall and a hop and
olson's gonna cruise into second with a
double
well he stays hot to begin the second
half and that'll bring up moreland
and this is of course the first at-bat
for this cleanup hitter today
3-1 pitch to moreland and mitch it's a
line ride down the right field line for
a base hit
and these take a one-nothing lead olson
around third to score easily
moreland goes to second with a double
and it's one nothing
athletics in the bottom of the first now
i feel there's room in left center the
infield playing straight up in the
delivery and that's a ground ball cris
lead off the mount back in
sprawling a short right center camp
throws to first on a hop
dug out by olsen what a play on both
ends
sparkling for the a's and that's out
number one
and garcia sets up outside it's a live
drive right to elvis to step to his
right he back in as the ball have a saw
fly drive and that's it for hedges
and the indians in the second the wind
up and here it is and seth it's a ground
ball
to jose ramirez charging and he bobbles
he throws the first not in time
ramirez set up as the only indian left a
second
on the left side of the infield a little
mishandled there
by the time he fired to first brow was
across the bag
and it's rolled an infield single when
these have their third hit
here's the pitch swaying and a missed
strike three
kemp was flailing away at a curveball
that time quantrill strikes him out with
it
here's the pitch to him swung on broken
bad looper
behind the mound picked up by rosario
throws on the run
and he gets him at first base catcher
running
and that helped rosario gets the job
done side retired we head to the third
daniel johnson who grew up here in the
bay area
line driving a base hit to center field
so
jett johnson and his return home as a
base hit in his first at-bat
trying to go with that fast ball away
but i don't think he got it away
and again they wanted to go upstairs
with it
two and two the pitch a split swing and
a miss and down he goes
fernandez chases it comes away empty
that's the second
strikeout for montas one two pitch
pulled on the ground right side it hits
off the body of johnson he'll be out
and that will end the inning so johnson
trying to avoid the bouncing ball
trying to jump over to makes contact
with him at the baseline that's an out
and that's it for the indians in the
third no run to hits
reyes struck out his first time on a
split 2-2
fastball right in at the knees reyes
gonna look it
97 a power sinker for montas
his third k second time on reyes back
with the o2 comes monta
swinging at a foul tip and did he hold
on
garcia did and gone on strikes is
bradley
back-to-back case for montas here comes
harold
ramirez frankie turns and the pitch
swinging amidst the back goes flying
over the mound behind the mound and
ramirez
is gone and one two three as motos
strikes out the side some boos for
ramirez and a look back by frankie motas
and that's what it ends up being and
nothing more so five k's now for frankie
and stephens the indians have three
there's room in right center left outer
hitter garcia sets up outside
swung out of miss on a splitter away
that's four straight strikeouts for
frankie six for the game and that'll
bring up
austin hedges there's a liner and a base
hit into left field
for austin hedges indians with a one out
base runner here in the fifth
potential tying run on base and now the
indians have something going here in the
fifth first
and second one out the pitch by montas
swung on and there's a high fly ball hit
to deep right
back on it the right fielder brown he
leaps at the wall can't make the play
it bangs off the wall rounding third
heading for home is hedges
he will score the tying run
johnson to third and into second with an
rbi
double cesar hernandez
he has tied this game and won here in
the fifth
now rosario steps in and he lines one to
deep
center back on it lorianno makes the
running catch
plenty deep enough for johnson to tag he
scores
and the indians take a 2-1 lead on a
matter of three pitches you have a hit
and two hit batters and boy is this
inning unraveling he has just set it up
for oakland
patrol with the 0-1 swung on grounded to
third
ramirez comes home for one hedges to
first
double play moving up the base runners
to second and third but the indians
turn two five two three
and they remain in front ace is loaded
two out and the two one pitch to
moreland
high fly ball centerfield zimmer
makes the catch the a's leave them
loaded cal cuatro works out of it
sandlin 1-0 with a 185 era and 23
appearances he has really been
one of the bright stars up and coming
really in that bullpen
got him backed up on the slider and
strike to not run away
so sandlin opens with a strikeout nice
catch
beautifully done by nick sandlin strikes
out kemp looking to end the six
reyes oh for three with a pair of
strikeouts today
big mountain of a man stands in from
that right side
swung on and there's a high fly ball to
deep center this
is hit a ton way back there home run
reyes
into the sweets in dead center
and front mill reyes has put the indians
in front
three to one emmanuel klosse
coming on the pitch here in the bottom
of the eighth inning you get knocked off
the horse you get right back on and
let's go
now the 2-2 swing and a miss strike
three
got him with the hard stuff at 100.
now the right-hander sets up high here's
his pitch
swing gonna miss strike three got him
with the hard stuff
at 98 clase perfect in the eighth with a
pair of strikeouts we head to the night
we're gonna hand it over to karen check
now and see if he can close it out
the athletics have the tying runs on
base
and throws to murphy swung on and driven
to right mercado back on this at the
track he's there he has the play and
makes the catch
on the warning track chapman tags and
scores but brown has to get back to
first
it's a 3-2 ball game
up the middle knocked down by karen
check scrambles after it
and he's going to hold on to it and
cannon's got a hit
mark drilled the ball into the glove of
karachek he kind of stumbled and rolled
away from him
trying to end it right here
ground ball ahmed long throw
in time book it the indians
win it by one run hanging on for the
victory here in the
bottom of the ninth inning and james
karenchick with his
tenth save of the season